and joining us here in the studio to
talk a little more about the promise and
potential dangers of gene therapy is
Wolfgang look at he is the president of
the German Society for gene therapy
thank you so much for being with us
today now the idea of gene therapy has
been around for decades but it's only
only seen limited success why is that
yeah I think one of the the problems was
the the transfer vector that is used to
bring a new gene into a cell so this
vectors at the beginning we are not
really safe all right what is the risk
sign associated with that the risk is
that they integrate in our genome at the
wrong place and then we have side
effects and the side effects can be
other diseases like leukemia for
instance okay this is that's a pretty
heavy side effect what is the what can
be done to minimize the risks or the
side effects yeah this has already
started years ago to improve the vectors
now we have a new generation of vectors
that are really safe because they can
integrate in a certain point of the
genome at specific sequences and we have
safety modules that are included in the
vector and in the gene modified sets and
P simply can switch off the vector and
can eliminate the cell all right is this
leading to greater approval then of gene
therapy yeah I think this fill that
improves gene therapy very much all
right let's talk about some of the
ethical issues surrounding gene therapy
what are they
yeah the ethical issues are that I think
one has to select very well the disease
which one want to treat because this is
a three component system you have to
manipulate a cell you have a gene that
you have to transport into the cell and
you have to make a vector choice and
this has to be very designed all right
well having said that then where does
gene therapy look the most promising in
curing which diseases specifically so we
have seen this here this mono genetic
diseases meaning that only one gene has
to be corrected this
relatively simple I would say it's more
challenging if we go to cancer because
cancer is a multifactorial disease and
there are many many gs genes are
included and we have to correct each
individual effect each individual gene
okay now um we asked for some commentary
on our Facebook page and I like ooh Alam
boo goo says he thinks that gene therapy
is okay as long as it can be used for
therapeutic purposes and nothing else
but could gene therapy technically be
used to enhance certain features like
our looks or our intelligence yeah I
mean there is a little danger because we
have increasing knowledge growing
knowledge how things are organized in
our body what other sequences and one
cannot completely exclude that that can
happen mm-hmm all right well back to the
ethical issue you know that is a
definite question there and finally what
is the future for a gene therapy look
like I'm quite optimistic I think that
in a decade or into that many people
diseases will be cured by gene therapy
so it's a very positive outlook that
you're giving us yes all right well we
thank you very much for this discussion
today Wolff chronic right